for our empathetic president to just
walk away from all of this knowing that
he facilitated all of this without any
plan for transition is really despicable
it's quite despicable and by the way
subjecting 38 million people to the
predations of some of the worst people
on planet earth disaster continues to
roll out in afghanistan the taliban are
doing what they do best namely torturing
and murdering people
so video has now emerged of the taliban
torturing translators for example and
people who had translated on behalf of
the american military who was there
and then yesterday apparently there were
people who were carrying afghanistan's
old flag you know the non-taliban flag
that was flying over kabul until just a
couple of days ago and the taliban did
what they do best they just opened fire
into the crowd according to al-aribiya
members of the extremist group opened
fire on the crowd at least two people
that at least 10 people injured here is
some of the video
you can see people begging to leave i
mean this is
it's it's
for for our empathetic president to just
walk away from all of this knowing that
he facilitated all of this without any
plan for transition is really despicable
it's quite despicable
but as we'll see
president biden when it comes to this
sort of stuff is pretty despicable in
general here's some video of afghan
girls begging in the american military
to take them with them because they know
what's going to happen which is
effectually sex slavery for everybody
under a particular age
[Music]
i remember when people say well you know
they're just going back to the lifestyle
that they chose they're just going back
to what they knew before many of these
girls have never known this lifestyle
the united states invaded afghanistan in
2001 it is now 2021 girls who are 18 19
20 years old have never lived under the
taliban they do not remember what it is
like to live under the taliban if you're
under 25 years old in afghanistan this
means you have never really experienced
a taliban rule in a way that you can
remember because again the united states
took over the country in 2001 and then
handed it over to our afghan allies
so the the
bizarre idea that this was approved by
the afghan population generally speaking
particularly in the major cities that
were controlled by the united states
like like
kabul is quite crazy it's quite crazy
and you can see the fallout from this
here for example is the first afghan air
force pilot who is female her name is
rahmani
pleading for president biden to hear her
to save the families of people who
worked with the united states who are
going to get stuck there all these women
by the way are going to get raped all
these women are going to get sold into
sex slavery if you're a single woman you
will by 13 14 years old have been
married off to somebody if not raped or
you will be married and then raped that
is the way things worked under the
taliban from 1996 to 2001 when they ran
the place and that has come back
in spades
here is this afghan female pilot talking
about it
as an afghan woman
i would like for president biden to hear
me the government that please save the
families that they need you the woman
the little girls that they always
looking up open to the united states the
great army that united states uh brought
to afghanistan and also please save my
family
well the good news is that the media are
apparently dedicated to the proposition
at least to a certain extent that the
taliban might be okay you're starting to
see this theme running through the media
not everybody in the media i think there
are some people in the media who are on
the left and are surprisingly actually
doing some honest media coverage i think
you've seen this from for example
richard engel over at nbc news i think
you've seen this from jake tapper over
at cnn there are some members of the
media who are still doing some honest
media coverage of this but i think the
tendency over the coming days is going
to be to suggest that the taliban have
in some way moderated in the same way
that the media went along with the
narrative that the iranian regime had
moderated and therefore it was time for
the united states to make concessions to
the milocracy i think you're going to
get that from the taliban as well with
regards to the media the taliban know
how to play this so the taliban
spokesperson yesterday for example said
yeah you know women do have rights you
know we're going to acknowledge women's
rights now and then they add the little
phrase that makes all of that mood that
comply with sharia
if you say that women have rights that
comply with sharia that means women
don't have rights okay sharia law in the
taliban's interpretation of islamic
fundamentalist law means women do not
have rights but here they are saying
what they think the west wants to hear
the question
what kind of guarantees can you provide
for
ensuring women's rights
as i said
the women are going to be very active in
the society
but within the frameworks of islam
uh within the frameworks of islam under
sharia
by the way this is why women young girls
are already being sent home from school
like already
that is the wonderful zabihullah mujahid
i'm sure we'll hear more from the
spokesperson for the 8th century
barbarian taliban malala yousafzai who
you'll recall was hailed the world over
for her willingness to fight for women's
education in afghanistan she now writes
in the new york times in the last two
decades millions of afghan women and
girls received an education now the
future they promised is dangerously
close to slipping away the taliban who
until losing power 20 years ago barred
nearly all girls and women from
attending school and doled out harsh
punishment to those who defied them are
back in control like many women i fear
for my afghan sisters
she says afghan girls and young women
are once again where i have been in
despair over the thought they might
never be allowed to see a classroom or
hold a book again some members of the
taliban say they will not deny women and
girls education or the right to work but
given the taliban's history afghans
women's fears are real already we are
hearing reports of female students being
turned away from their universities
female workers from their offices none
of this is new for the people of
afghanistan
she says that she's going to try and
funnel money in there but uh good luck
to her good luck to her
because the taliban is not going to
allow any of this and everybody knows
that this is the case at this point and
then the desperation of people
attempting to leave is just overwhelming
i mean there was a picture that was
making the rounds yesterday that is
shocking right this is a picture of a
man's legs
from underneath the wheel well
of a plane this would be an american jet
hey they're above the cloud line so they
are thousands of feet high this person
grabbed onto the wheel well of a plane
in an attempt to escape we already know
according to politico that one man his
body was found mangled in the wheel well
of an american c-17
hey you know what kind of desperation it
takes in order to do that some pretty
significant desperation by the way the
taliban has been shooting at afghans
near the airport so anybody who is
attempting to escape the taliban are
shooting
joe biden decided it'd be a good idea to
hand the country back over to these
people this is this would be a great
idea
all it took was maintaining a bare bones
troop presence 2 500 troops
in a support capacity fixing airplanes
and he decided not worth it let's leave
these barbarians in charge of a country
of 38 million people probably that'll
provide no threat to the united states
in terms of an uptick in in terror
threat
and by the way subjecting 38 million
people to the predations of some of the
worst people on planet earth
there was a time by the way when joe
biden who is now ardently against nation
building he said there was an
alternative to nation building since
2003.
in some parts of the administration
nation building is still a dirty phrase
but the alternative to nation building
is chaos
a chaos that churns out bloodthirsty
warlords drug traffickers and terrorists
and we have we've seen it happen in
afghanistan before
and i am quite frankful fearful it may
happen again
ooh just um yeah well he's changed his
tune somewhat by 2010 by the way
this is what's so amazing when you look
to your politicians for empathy you are
looking in the wrong place you're
looking in the wrong place it is stupid
to look to your politicians for empathy
i first of all i don't think the
politicians should operate on the basis
of empathy i think they should operate
on the basis of rational calculation i
don't think joe biden does either i
don't think he operates on the basis of
empathy or on the basis of rational
calculation but just to remind you for
all those people who believe that joe
biden is a kindly old grandfather figure
here's what joe biden had to say in 2010
about pulling out of afghanistan so
richard holbrook had a diary richard
holbrook was the special envoy from the
obama administration to afghanistan and
pakistan and holbrook
asked biden about america's obligation
to maintain presence in afghanistan to
protect vulnerable civilians and here is
what biden responded
f that we don't have to worry about that
we did it in vietnam nixon and kissinger
got away with it
f that well
man is true to his word f that and f
those people by the way again our
weaponry is now in the hands of these
barbarians
according to jake sullivan the national
security adviser who did just a
cataclysmically bad performance
yesterday in front of the press i mean
this is just a catastrophe in terms of
public relations the national security
adviser jake sullivan rhodes scholar
genius all the way around obama hold
over he says oh yeah by the way billions
of dollars of our weaponry is now in the
hands of the taliban
what happens to the billions of dollars
worth of weaponry that the us gave
afghanistan does the u.s have a plan for
that or does it remain in the taliban
we don't have a complete picture
obviously of where every article
uh of defense materials has gone but
certainly a fair amount of it has fallen
into the hands of the taliban and uh
obviously we we don't
have a sense that they are going to
readily hand it over to us at the
airport
we don't have a sense they're going to
of course they're not going to hand it
over give them billions of dollars in
sophisticated weaponry
of course you know they're gonna come
they're gonna they're gonna show up with
their mraps and be like you know what
guys we know that you're leaving and
just a parting gift we decided to give
you back just billions of dollars in
military hardware including
sophisticated drone technology
by the way we are busily trying to scrub
any biometric
materials that we have in afghanistan
because the taliban are going through
all of that stuff and they are finding
everybody who worked with us and then
they are murdering those people
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content